GARY: It's very raw - so raw that you don't think it can do as well as it can if we do something else.
DROCK: Do you know what I love, when you go on and you're changing your thoughts, this is not a step where you are formulating them.
GARY: Correct. DROCK: I don't think we need 45 minutes of it. GARY: I think you're wrong. DROCK: Okay.
GARY: We do what you are saying all the time.
GARY: You have to have an off-speed pitch to set up your fastball.
GARY: Even if the project doesn't succeed. It's a success.
GARY: Guys, this is amazing. You have to understand it. I for sure don't think it's gonna go viral.
GARY: No, no, I'm just talking. I can't wait to hear what Andy says.
GARY: I want it this way because I think of things as a holistic thing, not in the silo.
ANDY: We need to package that.
ANDY: Your words
when it's least on the dot-com.
GARY: Great! Guess what? You just fucking recorded it. DROCK: Yeah, I know. GARY: Dear fucking fans,
ANDY: Do you want these 11 tracks? Do we definitely want them to be videos versus audio?
GARY: Yes. ANDY: We definitely want them to be videos? Okay.
GARY: We want video, audio, and the written word. Listen - I totally get it.
GARY: If you think of it in the micro.
GARY: I think the macro of it is what helps the overall thing. ANDY: DRock and I were talking.
ANDY: Basically he's like 'some of it is hard to watch'. GARY: That's interesting, nobody's ever seen that from me.
ANDY: Like that's how it was, like that's his whole theory about everything.
DROCK: That's how I want to package it like. This is the document.
GARY: Great news. Great news.
GARY: Literally.
GARY: Hey everybody.
GARY: That's how we thought about launching this project. Here's your intro to the fucking plane project. I hope you enjoy it.
GARY: That's meta. From the second week, from the beginning. That's all I want.